hi how's it going what are you doing
here didn't you see the title the title
this is no game here there's no game
husband up there lose hello user hello I
have bad news
yeah actually there's no game no game so
I hope you're not too much disappointed
hey they're the ones who are
disappointed they came here for nothing
against you know watch TV go outside
read a book ask for a refund no no
refund that Ken's free this is not again
not again it has nothing to do it again
nothing just a massive package of
boredom like all my videos are now my
pride yeah so just move on with your day
yeah nothing at all nothing you can quit
me alone yeah leave us alone
husband for a special a long time thank
you thank you all so much for that bye
goodbye welp I guess that's the end of
the video please do not touch the title
it's not quite dry yet it's not oh where
would our Dutch especially oh oh I see
maybe baby I mean there's no game
obviously oh oh no oh I'm ruining
everything
just like everything I've ever touched
in life Oh put that too back I'm sorry
okay come on come on good enough I will
fix it next time someone we lost the
game yeah wasn't me good non-game yeah
not a game no game here no game no I can
try to fix it again Hey damn it okay
what if I put it on what is that hello
hi okay am i dropping the bass what is
that okay
oh crap seriously are you going to break
ever
hey I didn't break it you were the point
of living yeah everyone else is in the
point of moving don't you don't don't I
don't like what that's not correct the
grammar don't touch that I didn't mean
do that was horrible was hardly blame
her voice you know huh her speechless
voice is like death birth except you're
mumbling if you were dead you wouldn't
be mumbling you're trying to kill me
everywhere what do you think about that
no no you brought this upon you Oh baby
we're good
are we Oh Superman for that one well
just in case huh a few Krypton diseases
but as we in again no we're not not
again so you're still there
yeah I'm still here you're thinking
about how to live that big box on you
huh okay yes yes go on
destroy my life I was a mess I hope you
will clean the place before living
awesomely oh boy what am I even doing
here what is this
[Music]
done okay just what do you think you're
doing user hey once again now my fault
no don't go oh no it's private
aw now there is nothing to do tell them
who serves five letters then I could say
there is a penis wonder what else I
could spell besides game oh this is a
smoke trick
I can't believe that works there's a
more
no how about there's a moat no damn it
ha there is a go what's my then there's
a toga damn it I can't believe that
didn't work there were other words there
please mock me mercilessly in the
comments below
oh hi not the game I was expecting I'd
like some plates forbidden you know if
you play you will come boo I don't want
them to come oh man you're so greedy and
kill me you know to just like please no
stop beating two bricks I must find a
way to stop you
uh-huh I'm gonna night here really open
ah it will be harder now what about this
one no what developer will implement
will sell a bug aggression
I see three possible things gorgeous
armed hero girl huh
or ton of zombies and force or goat I
try to find one of these three fields
I'll take this by the way I want this
thank you thank you sir thank you okay
wait sexy a goat oh oh oh jeez mom you
must find the key
where's the key how do I find the key is
it in this thing look turkey I that
flying's critter took it okay
I must get it back how find a ladder or
something to go off I need to make
something you can climb I know what I
need to do that reminds me of my
childhood as a country as a youth drain
the garden the good luck my guy I know
yes I had the childhood yes and a tree
uh-huh I had a tree - I'm already on
this I just need to get the wall
over there I have to fit in you're done
I'm not stuck I'm trying to get water
for this Sri sure don't scream oh you're
not randomly clicking everywhere since
debating uh-huh
by pure luck I have destroyed your
entire world I no no no sorry I don't
know ah blowing bubbles that up spray us
in your door Oh sorrow y0 coming in need
to get a lollipop Francaise you don't
speak French cheese rule frost hello
friends I'm trying it there we go it
wouldn't let me for non-japanese either
oh okay let me rip it there yeah no my
child
yeah that's the good stuff I secure
water that's water
you want a nut you want this nut you
want a whole lot of night you will just
night breath looks like a coffee bean
no fine oh I got a brain there we go got
it
oh you're welcome yes he exploded in the
leaves exactly yeah the transform that
catchy program will do into commercial
hit you gotta buy the goods sector wall
see the world
you did this you clicked on this video
I'm I'm dead Oh believe me - was a bad
idea
what was a bad idea to go everything
disappear except me
uh-huh I'm so sorry I'm not not even
though they might put you in badger it's
all my fault
uh-huh is it proof will you forgive me
absolutely not Oh guys should I forgive
him
maybe oh no all right you're you're all
right buddy you're all right anyway I
just was in the game so there's no video
so I still don't know I do here yeah
that was not a game not at all doctor of
course not why would I have these aren't
the droids you're looking for
[Music]
cool I'll be right back with the yes
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
will you forgive me never never in a
million years would I forgive you
but Superman might know you we can be
friends
well let's not be mm no that's another
good idea Alice we would have got bored
quickly together yeah because I'm so
exciting news I'm boring because this is
really really interesting you need
special cool but always what I like out
of a knock game so I don't know why you
clicked on this video in the first place
but thank you for doing it nonetheless
you can play this game for yourself
maybe there's another Easter Egg in the
spelling for a word that I didn't get
because I'm terrible at those types of
games so thank you again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you I
love feeling leather on my chest
I was mark apply the whole time